hiccup and toothless are more than just
friends they're family we've compiled
some of their best moments into one
single video and believe us when we say
it's a real tearjerker this video
contains mega spoilers so you've been
warned keep watching to find out which
moment was voted in as number one
[Music]
playing fetch How to Train Your Dragon 3
the hidden world is by far one of the
best movies we've ever seen it doesn't
matter if you're a 10 year old girl or a
40 year old man chances are you're going
to bawl your eyes out before we dive
into some of toothless and hiccups most
heartfelt moments let's take a look at a
hilarious one hiccup and toothless might
be equals but they don't stray too far
away from the pet owner dynamic we were
reminded of this when toothless nudged
hiccups arm ask him to play fetch okay
well he didn't exactly ask but hiccup
knows how to read him pretty well
the last thing we were expecting was for
hiccup to take off his prosthetic foot
and used it as a dragon toy this scene
was super hilarious and it made pet
owners everywhere snort into their
popcorns hiccup is quick to remind
toothless that his leg isn't a chew toy
but whether or not the dragon got the
message is for you to decide toothless
later tries to play fetch with Astrid
who's immediately disgusted by the slimy
prosthetic the alpha dragon is in his
prime and he just wants to have fun but
from the looks of it dragons are just
huge fire-breathing dogs who could fly
toothless saves hiccup hiccup and
toothless happen through so much
together everyone back home had dragons
of their right so when they ride into
battle hiccup isn't merely riding a
dragon like a knight does a horse no
peace part of a team were both dragon
and Viking have each other's backs early
on in the movie we see hiccup Astrid in
the gang rescuing dragons from a ship
hiccups got his flaming sword and he's
putting it to good use
toothless is doing his part by locking
up the bad guys there's a moment where
toothless and hiccup work together to
lock an enemy in a cage here we can see
just how in sync these two friends
really are their connection goes beyond
words after locking up the bad guy
hiccup turns to his dragons to pat him
on the nose and say thank you this
moment is both hilarious and moving it's
funny because toothless and
GUP are in the middle of a big battle
but they still have enough time to be
kind to one another they're literally
the best team ever both these characters
are in their prime and kicking butt and
as Valka once mentioned they get along
super well because they're about the
same age
this scene flashed across the screen
pretty quickly but it's still managed to
hit home the king of dragons with the
help of his friends and supporters
hiccup has managed to build a dragon
utopia and Lau the people of Berk seemed
to be happy under hiccup's rule it's
easy to see that things are getting a
bit crowded hiccup and his crew returned
to Berk with even more dragons making
their home seem that much smaller the
dragons are going nuts with excitement
in fact things are getting out of hand
but when the camera zoomed in to show us
what hiccup and toothless were doing
viewers couldn't help but laugh out loud
hiccup was Petty and toothless while
same who's the king of dragons if
anything he was just riling up his
dragon even more so Gobber was quick to
point out that having the king of
dragons was useless if he couldn't
control the other dragons so toothless
snapped out of his happy state and
turned alpha which reminded the other
dragons to behave by the end of the
scene it's pretty obvious that Gobber is
a little fed up with Burks crowded
States to add fuel to aspire he stirs
his pot of soup only to find a baby
dragon taking a bath in it
hiccup the worst wingman ever this
hilarious moment had fans bursting into
laughter by now we all know that hiccup
isn't the smoothest Viking in all the
lands regardless he still managed to win
Astrid over and that's saying something
when toothless first comes face-to-face
with the light fury he can't believe his
eyes he approaches her in the forest and
starts encircling her in disbelief she
gets a little spooked and sends a blast
flying his way but it collides with the
tree and sends it toppling over
just when toothless is starting to win
the dragon over take a panache sure to
make some noise
pausing her to fly away toothless is
visibly upset he tries to chase after
her but looks back at his human friends
instead he gives them an angry look that
says thanks for ruining my chances write
that in there we see how sorry hiccup
really is he obviously feels bad for
scaring off toothless's love interest
the look that toothless and hiccup share
says more than words could have
toothless has just learned
valuable lesson hiccup is the worst
wingman ever
this moment was featured in the movies
trailer because it's both adorable and
amusing at the same time hiccup makes a
comeback toothless and light fury score
teen stage is definitely one of the
highlights of the movie we get to see
how similar the dragon is to his owner
in other words toothless ain't so smooth
himself he goes on his first date with
light fury and ends up tumbling down a
sand hill and embarrassing himself but
he's quick on his feet and soon makes a
comeback unlike last time hiccup watches
quietly from the sidelines and helps
toothless impress his female friends
toothless is strange behavior is
definitely making an impression on light
fury to say the very least the Night
Fury even draws a picture for his future
girlfriend hiccup is doing everything he
can to help out his friend it's obvious
that he wants his dragon to find love
and be happy light fury seems to be
having a good time
despite toothless is curious courtship
methods so she soon invites him to go
for a flying session sadly toothless
still can't fly on his lonesome so he
watches light fury become a speck in the
sky while desperately trying to fly
after her toothless is obviously smitten
by the snow-white dragon and no one is
happier for him then hiccup we were
happy to see hiccup redeem himself by
the end of this scene toothless looking
sharp
when hiccup sees light fury fly away
without toothless a little piece of his
heart breaks so he rushes home to build
his friend a tale that he'll be able to
steer all by himself
Astrid points out that hiccup has been
working on the design all night proving
just how dedicated he is to toothless is
freedom Astrid also mentions that
toothless has never wanted a tail like
this before and hiccup goes on to tell
her that he's never had a reason to fly
alone before now toothless is so excited
to get his new tail that he's even seen
helping hiccup build it hiccup tells
Astrid that he wants his dragon to be
happy unlike some pet owners hiccup
loves toothless more than he loves
himself and he knows that when you truly
love something you should set it free
toothless can hardly contain his joy
when hiccup is putting on his new
prosthetic once properly secured
toothless runs off and takes flights he
looks back at hiccup with a thankful
look of just how close these two really
are hiccup puts on his best Viking voice
and tells toothless to be home by
down at the latest we absolutely loved
this moment
toothless goes after hiccup toothless
and hiccup share a bond that can be hard
to understand so when light fury comes
into the picture she's under the
impression that toothless is owned by
hiccup she never could have imagined
that toothless was living on Berk out of
his own sheer will
hiccup wants nothing more than for light
fury to live on Berk alongside toothless
and everyone else he just wants to be
one big happy family but light fury is
Pharaoh and considers toothless to be an
unwanted third will this hilarious scene
brings the revelation to light when
hiccup sees light fury approaching him
in the sky he thinks that she's finally
chosen to join them so imagine his big
surprise when she grabs him by the
shoulders and sends him hurtling towards
the ground her actions caused the other
Vikings to share a big laugh but hiccup
is definitely not laughing it's here
that we realized that toothless has a
choice to make he could fly away and
live a happy life with light fury or
save hiccup and go back to Berk he
chooses to save his pal but not before
giving light fury a special look it's
clear that toothless is super faithful
to hiccup and let's just say that the
feeling is mutual
hiccups realization we hope you have
some tissues on hand because this scene
is sure to invoke a waterfall of Tears
it's old news that toothless is the king
of dragons he's taken down two alphas
and has quite the reputation
when hiccup and Astrid tried to save
toothless from the hidden world they
quickly realized that toothless is
somewhat of a celebrity there on top of
that they also realized that the hidden
world is the real dragon utopia
toothless takes his place at the top and
light fury sweetly nuzzled him while
showing him off to the rest of the
Dragons
toothless looks happier than ever which
is a hard truth for hiccup to swallow
for the first time he finds out that his
dragon can be happy without him and the
look of realization on his face hit us
right in the fields one by one all of
the dragons start bowing down to their
new king toothless is to the hidden
world what hiccup is to Berk and both
kingdoms neither chief with them at all
times
all this time hiccup thought that light
fury would come live on Berk with
toothless only to realize that it was
the other way around the final goodbye
the majority of pee
who watched How to Train Your Dragon 3
the hidden world had nothing but good
things to say however they did mention
that the threequel was super emotional
toothless and hiccup have shared some
pretty amazing moments and although most
of them are funny in light some of them
are sad and heavy and there's one scene
we simply can't stop thinking about it's
the final goodbye after helping hiccup
defeat his enemy toothless and his
friend both realize it's time to say
goodbye in hiccups own words toothless
has looked after them for long enough so
the two best buds look at each other in
the eye and come to an agreement
toothless will take the Dragons back to
the hidden world where it's safe for
them to live in harmony the world simply
isn't ready for dragons but hopefully in
one day we'll be toothless and hiccup
share a big bear hug and at this point
viewers were openly weeping in fact
redditor bud jake took to the Internet
to say I'm a 250 pound man and I cried
like a baby at the end the reunion fans
were thrilled to see that How to Train
Your Dragon 3 was going to end on a high
note after all there was no way viewers
would have been happy with a tearful
ending so the last scene of the movie
brought forth one of the bests hiccup
and toothless moments ever after letting
the dragons go hiccup and Astrid get
married and have two children
the family decides to venture to the
hidden world to say hello to their
father's old friend
hiccup looks very different in fact he's
managed to grow a full beard
so when toothless first sees him he's a
little confused the dragon gives hiccup
a once-over and slowly approaches and
hiccup holds his hand out for toothless
to smell when he realizes who he's
smelling he jumps on hiccup and starts
giving him kisses this scene made
everything okay and fans were able to
leave the cinema with smiles on their
faces instead of tears hiccup and
toothless are the best of friends of all
time and they've left us with an
important message when you really love
someone you do what's best for them not
for you before you go let us know which
of these moments was your favorite and
that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up if you think hiccup and
toothless are the cutest the best
friends ever and subscribe to the things
for more awesome content to come your
way thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]